hey everybody I'm Alex and this is Mary
and we are playing inside from the
makers pretty good how are you doing man
I'm doing good i am walking around in
these leaves yes the leaves they sound
really cool you can crunch them this is
inside from the makers of limbo play
dead it is twenty dollars out today on
the xbox one out next week on pc its
console exclusive at the moment we don't
know what the future might bring um but
yeah we're gonna play inside for a bit I
tripped there a little bit yeah like
he's got a lot of animations from like
tripping and wishing and falling he's
got a lot of character for this little
dude who am I uh you're a little dude
not a script boy yeah it's sort of like
uh sort of like limbo you're a
nondescript boy figure yeah there's some
pretty eerie masked figures back there I
find it interesting that my character
automatically went into hide mode even
though I didn't do that yeah that wasn't
a button for me to look like I was
hiding no inside has a few of the
stealth moments there was sneaking oh
there's some more oh yeah those dudes
look they look like bad news alright so
this is this is already and a lot of
people probably have made this
connection that it looks so much like
limbo it seems like I'm gonna be hiding
around but if I were to have been found
how bad would it have got it gets pretty
bad if you remember limbo limbo deaths
are pretty violent this is pretty
similar yeah you get you get eviscerated
you know dismembered killed in all
manner of ways in this game I'm just a
little boy I know it the inside doesn't
care it'll rip you apart guess not yeah
alright well I'm observing this truck
and there's dog yes and there is a
fridge ooh okay I bet fridge cool sorry
I grabbed that with X yeah this is again
this is reminding me of limbo big remote
teaches you so slowly right yeah it
seems like even from them the big
it seems a lot like limbo the gameplay
at least oh yeah the the side-scrolling
the simple mechanics at first that
probably build although I'm making large
assumptions I've never played this
before but you have yeah did you review
this for us I actually did review it I
gave it an 8 out of 10 loved the game um
I played it twice actually so I'm really
interested to see what you think um Oh
God actually one of the biggest
differences between this and limbo that
I saw was the sort of art style and the
backgrounds and how lavishly their
detailed what do you what do you think
of that so far yeah limbo is like pretty
much gray style which I thought was
really unique at the time it was like
the only one that did something like
that yeah but it's really nice to see
them growing out of that although this
is very gray style oh no um run run okay
I don't know how to run you do not you
can yes oh man I was really intense why
did they stick a dog after me I'm
talking about oh I know they don't care
they must have seen me see something bad
but yeah like there's so much more
detail even though this is heavily dark
and there's not a lot going on you can
see lots of tints of green and blues and
like limbo was straight-up grayscale I
want us nothing up so there's a lot more
detail in this and there's a lot more
visual design they've put a lot more
efforts into the backgrounds and just
terms like you can see the leaves on the
trees and this one you can see
everything yeah I would describe it as
2.5 d like there's a lot of stuff
happening in the backgrounds like you
already saw a dog charged out of the
background right at you that was amazing
and that came from the background that
the original limbo I don't think could
afford to do that not even
technologically I don't think it was
capable of having something in the
background become the foreground right
so all right yeah so you've got this van
hi oh man you're already doing better
than I I was so I've never played this
before but i'ma tell you right now this
little nook looked important yeah
there's a lot of visual cues in these
games and it's important to see them but
another thing at least in the previous
game that I assume will happen is trial
by death which basically means you will
not get through this game and you're not
to get through this game on your first
playthrough in one piece you're meant to
die that's the only way you're gonna
learn yes exactly you're meant to die
you're meant to die a lot in this case
meant to run you're already doing way
better already I rap yeah I think at
this point I've already done I shouldn't
have done that oh yeah oh no he's good
Oh No okay so I died all right well that
was good to know there was a little
stick there that I fell over and now I'm
gonna do this again so he's meant to see
me yeah um where's that stuff so yeah
there you go yep more I'm gonna keep
jumping yes good work good work Oh No
you shot me oh yeah you just got lit up
he Wow Frank startles her bad men yeah I
didn't think that I would happen so I'm
not really sure where to go because
there's a guy behind me so this is a
really interesting first thing to get
stuck on so jump right but then what
look there's a service can I use it yeah
all right oh god that guy's me you want
to get out nice work remember that yep
see you're supposed to stop oh god he
shot me know right away I'm just a boy
keep running their dogs after you yes
there's multiple dollars yeah they send
their dogs
ok cool I assume I can swim yeah how
would just be cruel yes you can swim in
this game which is big if you remember
limbo you would die if you touch why
it's pretty unforgiving like you just
get wrecked oh they shot me with a dart
yeah which is like kind of like murder
by association because they didn't kill
me but I'm in water yo yeah like
obviously I'm gonna not be able to
breathe um this is interesting i think i
need to learn how to die exactly ok um
ok there you go there is no button to
dive i just hit down mm-hmm not natural
dive here now all games I can't swim
forever it looks like I'm yeah so you'll
hear all right I I went to brown all
right I'm figuring it out here so I
learned from my controller vibrating
yeah it had um the boy will also make
some noises he looks like I'm past the
light you'll gasp a little bit when he's
drowning so mary did you think that the
the puzzles in limbo were hard I
personally did I got stuck on a few yeah
um now this was years ago when I was
dumber I'm really smart now but I think
when I was a kid uh you're just a young
kid how long how long ago was the first
fret limbo six years six years okay that
wasn't that long ago my kids six years
yes I was just a little we taught six
years ago um I really did struggle
especially towards the end there was a
remember specifically a box that needed
to float I need to like move it around
and took me I mean I was stuck yeah for
like 30 minutes that's a long time to
just be stuck on a puzzle and think
about it are there puzzles of this
caliber in this game oh man that box
puzzles that got me stuck as well
nothing that involved there are a couple
things that require a little bit of like
multi-step coordination but you
generally they after a couple deaths
probably you'll get them it in my
opinion that was actually one of the
improvements of this over over
limbo because the puzzles all keep you
very into the story like they keep you
very connected to the narrative and the
world more so than I felt that limited
yeah it's cool that like they've done a
little bit more connection sometimes I
felt like the war the rules in limbo
just changed for no reason almost
because it fit the form of a puzzle
whereas this one seems more narrative
Lee driven there's a lot of dead animals
around here so do you notice the do you
notice a little worm on one of them I
don't know if that's here yet wait are
these mice I know that those are little
chicks yeah they're following me oh I
didn't see worms um actually that might
be in the next in the next section but
they're old whalers is spoil the next
section boilers um your little chickies
follow me I will save you just kidding I
gotta leave you but I will come back for
you they need me all they can do is feed
off of that cow you're like the Pied
Piper of chickens this isn't she my
calling yes oh I made it dude did it
alright so i like the little church that
the chicks make it makes me sad oh god
oh this looks important alright so I got
some levers I got that thing got this
thing oh do I got I got wall I got a
wall and I want to get up there yeah
they do a great job with their lighting
just to like give them huge praise for
their design or if you see that there's
a light in the upper right-hand corner
that's like I mean it's pretty obvious
but I I just like want to make it clear
like that takes great design for them to
say here's a light at the beginning of
the puzzle you want to go to the light
at the end of the puzzle and they're
doing it subconsciously so not telling
you you know there's nothing in this
game that says hey you want to get over
there it's letting you know visually I'm
just gonna see if there's anything to
the left that I might have missed a door
Oh God watch
yeah I don't want the chickens to go
through the wood chipper yeah that's
where my eye that's like where my head
goes immediately because I love my
little friends I know they're so cute
and you get it no I don't know you can
survive roam around with them for a bit
uh they're gonna adorable they're gonna
survive you're gonna team up chicks I
hold on to something so let's see this
is interesting it's a ripcord it sure is
and it's starting this engine but it's
not continuing um occasionally you have
to I don't know what this one does
nothing happens when I do this so
occasionally you have to rip eye rip
cord more than one that makes sense
because when you have a lawn mower back
in the dizzay back today back when
you're six years ago I was just a one
time when limbo came out got it yeah
okay so oh so I want to push that hey
barrel off yes exactly i see it alright
so this puzzle annoyed me food racing on
got it so that helps but I there's not
enough stuff coming out of it to push
off the hey it's not and it's being
sucked through this tube right oh my god
little chick are you wait the chicks
don't die no okay all right I think I
got it so I want the chicks to hit it
exactly all right so these chicks are
gonna help me and I'm not gonna kill
them so if I time it all right I got one
shove one but I need I need to smash
more chicks so they follow me so I'm
gonna run to the end of this thing
exactly they'll follow me and based on
how slow they are because I'm a human
male and they are but we chickadees yes
I should be able to you are the dominant
force in this environment
nice catapulting the chicks so that's
the meanest they all they all lived
except one what you killed I do one of
them yeah I could feel bad this isn't
the kind of game I signed up for I know
right I killed it chicken it huh and you
believe them now hi chicken oh they
trusted me um well yeah to your previous
point what they what plated does so well
both with limbo in this is just is
indicate using lighting and using you
know environmental cues where to go and
what to do this fall will kill me will
it we landed on the pig body so you see
those you see those worms um like coming
off of the the pigs right there yes your
these long things so right so uh if you
remember in limbo you would occasionally
get a worm embedded in your head oh yeah
and it made you walk backwards oh no
what made you walk a direction yeah so
yeah I just thought that was interesting
uh-huh I feel like you're foreshadowing
I'm actually me I I honestly just think
it's interesting I'm not hinting at
anything I don't trust you I'm not i
would never spoils oh no oh no oh no I
thought I was getting caught in the mood
in the mood I thought that like
everything in the original limbo which
by the way in the original limbo I died
like 40 times by now so I'm really
amazed I've only died a couple times
you've been you've been killing it so
far I mean you've been doing way better
than I did so yeah that one's it is but
no that's a butt worm some better news
but this is it's a better than five yeah
oh my god I made a call I decided to
jump over him there you go hey I knew I
could have something
it killed that pig
oh my god I gotta kill him run where oh
my god I don't have anywhere to go there
you go okay you it's in his butt still
hey don't touch it he might have to
touch it I don't want to know I'm not
going to can I go up these stairs it
seems reasonable no its other you can't
go back there's all these people back
there I recognize it now oh you gotta
pull out its but worm he did it pull the
ribs but he looks okay yeah he's doing
using a little worse for wear but doing
right your pic friend now you a chick
you had chicken friends and I have a big
friend well I'm not very good to my
friends no I can't believe I pulled that
out of his butt so there's this thing
that's lit which looks important so I'm
gonna pull the pig towards it get it get
here oh it isn't wanna I know you man
your little boys exploitative these
animals just exporting these things
ya know so all right i am a zombie yeah
yeah control oh man you me that thing
hop yeah dude so man every time I i
watch this game I'm just so astounded by
the amount of detail in it and the
backgrounds and nice moments all right
you come over here so I'm learning a lot
right now all I've learned is that it
can make more of them to raise things if
two of them gets stuck they can wait did
I do it ok cool so what up my I'll be
friends huh hey guys man you have you
had chicken friends and you had a pig
friend I have zombie friends man you're
just making friends lifting right I
would like to get out of this yeah
device okay oh god this yeah I was
really stressful game is so dark
everything about that was really
stressful I like manipulated those
zombie people today well you were just
totally using a zombie people for your
selfish aims I wonder those people
wanted to kill me oh no i don't think i
have a strength to do this I know he's a
strong boy he's got a boy he's got the
strength of a zombie men exactly he was
eating his beats or whatever you do this
pulling out those but worm yeah with one
hand there's a bicep curl this is
beautiful yeah so inside was in
development for six years like basically
if they started on it right after at
limbo came out that's amazing I find it
really powerful that they were able to
stay in development for that long it's a
long time for a small team although to
be fair limbo wasn't actually a small
team it's perceived to be quite a small
indie team but I remember it being
almost a team of 70 wow that's crazy um
I think maybe including like marketing
and PR yeah yeah I would assume so but
it's like not a team of six like you
might have thought I mean it's still I
think I think inside it's still probably
developed the core team is probably
pretty small
but yeah it's that six years is
definitely a parent it's one of the
games that actually benefited from a
longer development time the craft is
just so evident let me ask you the
question that's probably on a lot of
people's minds would you consider this a
better game in limbo yes yes
unequivocally um yeah it is so much
better in the ways that like it improves
on everything that limbo was sort of
like what sort of flawed with um that's
better puzzles and as better narrative
it has better in my opinion way more
beautiful arts and this just more
involved and and just and basically
every way oh they don't trust me no well
it's good to know that they've learned a
lot from the original game which I found
to be quite a masterpiece from beginning
to end I mean certainly not perfect but
in terms of you know a game that I would
recommend to my peers to my family my
friends I would always suggest limbo
like what a stunning game it was yeah um
so I think it's great to know if this
game is better than that game which I
super liked it must be a darn good game
how long is this game three and a half
hours about might take you a little
longer depending on it might take you
Mary a little shorter because you're
killing it with these puzzles oh no I
already got it so I think what this is
telling me and I'm not entirely sure
here because I was able to rotate this
yeah yeah is that I need to rotate it so
i can jump exactly to the top alright
cool oh god don't drop i have not died
in a while uh it seems less gory than
the original is that not true I mean you
just haven't died um you uh do you like
my noises I don't someone I play tennis
too which is never cuz I don't play
tennis what Maria Sharapova noises yeah
no no
I saw it yeah late as soon as I dropped
it I knew I was in danger yeah it you're
definitely in a less Cory section it
gets very violent very violent which run
jump nice killed it killed it killed
those / ya can't believe I killed a
chick I know I mean to be 41 to use it
well screw that but work but leg you
kill you like see baby chickens like you
don't want to kill them what happens if
you go down here cool it's kind of like
investigating my surroundings this game
is like it's all about that really it's
all about exploring the space mm-hmm
uncovering secrets this might kill me
but I'm gonna go now you're good survive
you're good you open that I see a
blinking I'm trying an area yeah uh
what's that cuz there's a red my bread
switch with me actually don't know what
that does are you serious i found a sea
crow and I don't even know what its
purposes yeah I still don't know what
that is are you serious you finished it
I know you're washed it and you don't
know there are a lot of secrets in this
game that are fascinating I wonder if
you have to do it in a certain amount of
time or maybe like push the switch first
before you pull that lever maybe because
the second time i played through this i
didn't even do that and I be it again so
I am still not really sure what that's
about it's about if they're they're a
bunch of secrets in this game bought in
them that I missed so there's definitely
reason to replay this game mmm i'm not
sure what my goal is I know to do this
but my question is what do I do with
these people oh they're going opposite
directions okay interesting yes so
you're gonna have to coordinate these
two so that when they're walking apart
they step on it at the same time oh
there's a lever yeah so there are these
two white squares and I think they're
supposed to walk on them at the same
time right free okay so they need to be
farther apart yep it's hard to judge how
you do that because one of them walks it
oh I got it get out dang Mary killing it
I was like how cuz it's really annoying
because he walks into that hole and I
can't see him but I was like girl you
can change that at any time girl thus
the aha moment yes the Eureka moment is
very strong in this game I love that and
I I say this a lot when I play puzzle
games but I'd like to reiterate the
beauty of a good puzzle game is getting
the aha moment not the execution exactly
if you can say oh I I get it you should
be able to finish that puzzle now you
shouldn't be punished by having to
perfect it or doing it 20 times after
you got me aha yah yah ha is like the
epitome of said puzzle now I'd like to
move on second I realized to shut that
door um right then I had come to the
conclusion is this homage to the
original the original had letters like
this that's right that was one of my
favorite moments and then you really
loved it um this seems really similar
actually yeah oh this looks like it's
gonna kill me Oh touch anything no all
right Yolo just go for it
jump jump nice zombies in the round
zombo's with one supervisor yeah that's
a zomb oh yes zombo manager the hum bow
managing new mobile game coming to you
from the makers limbo zombo man shake it
up huh I need to push that but yeah I
agree with you I think that's one of the
things they disliked about limbo is that
there is some of those timing based
puzzles that you would get and you would
understand you wouldn't still die all
the time but you were like yeah I good
what do I down here yep box that was one
of the ones where like once I figured it
out it took me like six more tries yeah
yeah you'll get it oh no I'm gonna die
so inside does that so much better like
it it has so much so it stores a couple
of those with it so few so many figure
Yolo yeah your boys Anaka back yeah he's
got it he's got a pretty good now um oh
man i love how much mystery isn't yeah
he's in this game as well i'm like not
only am i interested in just surviving
like the original limbo but this one's
got a lot of world yes you know there's
something going on in this world that i
want to yeah and i'm a sucker for
post-apocalyptic you know dystopian
stories and this one's so Orwellian it's
so interesting to just like try to
figure out what's happening cool yeah oh
no no no okay sometimes you just wing it
oh no rats you rats you yeah I'm just a
boy don't touch me rats all right Oh
jump okay that wasn't it
okay what if I pushed it that might work
uh can I there you go yeah I want to be
on the other side all right leaver
leaves Oh God should not have done that
oh man you are correct you go away yup
boy you just got snatched what if I
don't pull the lever okay sucker oh man
that guy got oh man that were I'm rude
that could have been me that could been
any of us all right so that's an
interesting I guess it's not really a
puzzle but it's a learning lesson that
sometimes you don't wanna I mean pushy
the lover you do now but i gots to
survive can't be snatched I mean does it
move ok so i reek ran out there night
good nice nice Oh No went faster than
that light deftly button button
escape escape oh man I love the music or
the sound in this game do you hear that
sounds like a faint heartbeat like that
yeah I love it you know what that
reminds me of is the thing from John
Carpenter most of the music and the
thing was romper yeah I'm not gonna make
it so what are you thinking of the like
inspiration and the stories in this game
of the story in this game so far yeah I
definitely get like an oral or well yeah
vibe from it um like there's something
oh I'm sorry dude dude oh oh no whoa no
become boy become zombie I am zombie
yeah I have now become zombie sorry I
just wanted to see what happened um it
like definitely has a supernatural
factor to it almost like alien yeah
invasion style yeah stop and obviously
this game is already so much more like
blunt and upfront with a story then
limbo was like it's pretty clear that
it's dystopian and you know but at the
same time there's so much subtlety to it
that's great i love this part stop the
weird red light green light effect going
on here i'm wondering yeah like I was
cruel where it obstructed my view like
that alright so I'm going to watch and
see what the people have to do yeah look
at that overseas so they're jumping in
that circle they're just watching these
people is pork zombie people jump nice
continue I am one of you my zombie
friends come to me overseers I am a good
zombie yeah do not watch me too deeply
because I am something I but I am but a
zombie I'm but assuming all those people
are wearing the same okay so that
person's turning around to the left to
the left cha cha slide yeah now cha cha
real smooth zombie version oh I did that
really fast okay slow it down I was
across a friend I was aggressive zombie
turn oh no oh no sorry oh no I actually
thought I turned and I didn't enough
that was weird i wonder if it's gonna
make me do the whole puzzle again
because i will be annoying yeah but at
the same time i think that this sequence
is super good for the tone of the world
um yeah I get that it's teaching me the
rules and I'm cool with that um I'm just
uh just a ready to move on yeah i agree
with you
uh it seems like they're focusing on on
me pretty heavily that robot trusts me
he does not oh man I barely made that
it's tough out there for a fake zombie I
know just trying to make it in this
zombie were and make it in this zombie
world I'm but a boy left right so it
blinks when it's like not cool with what
I'm doing what is suspicious yes so one
of the reasons why I liked this game so
much is I like I generally have problems
with puzzle games because so often the
puzzles just feel disconnected from the
world like you end up just trying again
and again and again to get the puzzles
and set up actually like being in the
world or you know interacting with the
story at all I never played the witness
but I heard that they that does it that
that's pretty well the witness is like
yeah the penultimate example of here is
a trick now I'm going to build on it now
I'm going to build on it now I'm gonna
build on it and it keeps doing that so
much until your head explodes rice um so
exactly so that's like an example oh no
dog we don't know should I uh oh right
I'm ready yeah I've made the call get
out there get out of there jump nice oh
you make a you make a quick judgment
okay I'm not gonna make it oh my face Oh
took my jugular broke your neck yeah so
there's your violence there it is there
it is I have observed the violence all
right I'm not really sure what to do
about it I ran so he's basically
um nope God you got wrecked all right
that's not the solution oh wait if I
trick him to go down but then I go back
up maybe he'll get stuck there you go
that's a good that's a good yeah idea
dum-dum I got around dumb dog dumb idiot
dumb dumb oh yeah I would like you to
pull me away from her snug um wait if he
pulls me towards it will that dog eat me
probably you oh I don't let me the game
said no you solved this puzzle you
masochistic weirdo don't don't break the
game you Butthead don't get yourself
eaten okay yeah with a game like this
that's trying for a narrative feel like
it's definitely narrative first I kind
of hate it when puzzles like when
puzzles end up being done for the sake
of puzzles if you understand yeah and i
think this does that so well of just
making sure that the puzzles are an all
in service to something else yeah
they're really uh you know they're clean
and they're elegantly made like i can
see exactly what they're doing does it
escalate like limbo where you like I
currently I'm kind of breezing through
it would you say there's points where
like it gets pretty heavy later on I i
I'm I said God dang it because this took
me like 10 minutes to get um look at me
doing the moonwalk Michael Jackson uh
it s goes a little bit yeah they
definitely get more involved it in the
pace increases as well um so that's
gonna kill me interesting
can I walk through here no so this kills
the boy yes but there's stairs there so
I guess Oh easy man there is another one
of those head things up top man said the
time you might want to get your little
zombie friend up there what's he do them
so I can make him jump yeah what does
that double zombie action got double
zombie action that hot double zombie I I
got subs on yeah I didn't all about the
dub Tom's up song
doubled song doubles all right oh ok so
I'm I now this guy all right all right
I'm learning about the rest the rules
here I thought I was controlling zombie
number one but I wasn't rolling me right
so actually not sure how to solve that
just yet but I'm confident you can get
it oh my god he just thought there would
be a zombie in that cardboard box you
know they hide zombies everywhere just I
expected zombie I'm so confused so if I
drop it drops everyone yeah so Oh God so
then I have to restart the process yep
okay so it's either all zombie or nose
on I've got it
I understand they're young you did it I
understand there we go so much tom it's
great yeah I'm having a good time good
nice music in the background
I can't tell with you would you say it
might have been 20 minutes my god so
yeah it's been probably a little more
alright so I'm pretty sold how do you
get this game alright so this game is
actually out today on the xbox one for
twenty bucks oh no one won last death
for your little boy it's just a little
boy um yeah so it's out for twenty bucks
right now on xbox one I would highly
recommend you go get it it's amazing I
gave it an eight out of ten think it's
it's one of my favorite games the year
it's out next week on Steam and other
platforms for PC also for twenty bucks
and so that's just the the first few
like 25 minutes 20 you know of inside
there's a whole lot more a lot more
secrets a lot more puzzles survival I
more survival home or getting ripped
apart by dogs are there more but uh
worms Sally that's the only about worm
in the game I will score all that I'm
okay we know what brought worms alright
well thank you everyone for tuning in if
you're on YouTube you can like and
subscribe and we would really appreciate
that keep it a keep an eye on gamespot
for more about inside and thanks this is
Alex may have a good day thanks guys
you